um one of my favorite ones is having a
negative mindset versus a positive
mindset so when somebody says I'm no
good at that I always say add the word
yet at the end I'm no good at that yet
or I can't do that yet or I suck at that
for now right and instead of making
those insecure declarations final just
add a little bit of Doubt to the
negativity you start to find that you
have a more positive
point of view on what's possible and I
like doing it for other people when I
catch somebody saying well I I don't
know how to do that and I go yet you
know how to do that yet or you suck at
that right now so that that to me is
very easy to do and it pays David ends
of a Time